if I return me to the Fed right now I
would try to instruct both the president
his advisers and Congress that monetary
easing alone or monetary policy alone
can never revive the economy and that
without fiscal intervention on the part
of government we will be a very long
time before the consumer is able to
revive his needs and and and a very long
time before our budget will in any way
become balanced that the foolishness of
constricting a budget at this time in
the middle of a recession is politically
motivated but absolute absurdity
when you go to Reaganomics and you try
to release money to the rich in the hope
that it will trickle down to the others
we have proven time and time again this
is nonsense it doesn't trickle down
anywhere the man with a million dollar
income who makes another hundred
thousand dollars is more likely than not
not to spend it and he you generally
invest it in a secondary investment not
a primary investment he will create no
jobs with it he will create no
consumption with it normally the man who
earns $30,000 a year or right now
nothing and has some money added to that
will spend the money added to that
because he needs to spend the money
added to that and that will create
velocity of money in the marketplace and
that will create the beginnings of a
recovery conceptually we don't get it if
inflation is 2% but 60% of the inflation
figure has to do with labor who of
course are shrinking in terms of
salaries and an income that if then
inflation is actually 6% if inflation is
actually 6% and I think it's more than
that
and at the same time growth is 2% we are
in a recession
we're actually shrinking at 4% in terms
of goods and services circulating in the
country the idea of the political
motivation and
in terms of balancing a budget now we'll
absolutely kick back at the economy
regardless of whether the debt limits
arcs are extended or increased and will
drive the economy into the kind of
recession or depression that we had in
the 1930s and I think that you should
watch very carefully for the
possibilities of social unrest in this
country unless Washington wakes up
that's what I would say if you asked me
to become head of the Fed or any other
financial job in Washington